[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about whatever we want anthony's
here
for me julia and they said and for me
and 40 yeah that's hip hop that's street
lingo anthony
oh he got hip-hop for no reason hip hop
you don't stop to rock out a big bucket
broccoli beef
broccoli rock out of the broccoli beef
rocks with broccoli beef
yeah that's the old saying that we i
like that jacket
shirt looks like western meets eastern
oh yeah yeah
that's like karate about bloods and
crips
in there you know wow look at that show
the whole outfit oh actually it looks
like
how about that i work on a farm and i'm
about to get some
hay and create a haystack but i'm
japanese kind of
i'm gonna create a haystack in this not
cause it's like farmer material dude
farmer samurai yeah he's a farmer
samurai
a family
i'd be seeing [ __ ] like that on
instagram and then i i want to get stuff
like that
instagrams advertisements are so good
i'm like the perfect consumer for them
what have you bought
you know how they like i bought like the
[ __ ] the little ear
wax thing camera i've bought like so you
can see if there's ear wax yeah so you
can go in there and then like
pull it out and stuff i'm really looking
for gold but if the if the camera is
here how do you look at it you gotta
look it's like a little microscope
camera that's like at the end of you
ever seen this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
so it's like yes and it's like you look
at it and you're like oh that's nasty
here it plugs into your phone and so you
literally just like think
like you just go inside you never see
the inside of your ear like this yeah
that's the convenient thing to have a
tiny little camera because what if you
get something
stuck somewhere and you stick the camera
and you could see like not just in your
ear
you know can you can you see your brain
oh yeah can you no you can see your ear
drum though so you can see exactly
yeah what does an ear drum look like oh
it's like a percussion snare it's kind
of like a
tuna you tuned it right honestly it
looks like a little um like a
a small shell i don't know if i'm like
seeing the right thing it's like a small
shell that just kind of like
weird is that what it's called cochlear
yeah [ __ ]
clear i always called it eardrum oh yeah
cochlear cochlear yeah i think it's
cochlear
cochlear drug that's [ __ ] weird that's
your [ __ ]
i want to know what your hygiene routine
is my hygiene routine trying to learn
how to be cleaner
i mean you you groom yourself up pretty
well i know but
because me i'm trying to be fashion and
every time i come over here i just look
homeless
and then i look at this dude and i'm
like man you look like
a mannequin or something i'm sorry when
you said i'm trying to be more fashion
and they looked at you like yeah he's
rambo chic today
rainbow chic is
yeah i'm like rambo but like
okay my problem is rainbow one obviously
so like
so like in fashion right i noticed that
well at least listening to women
like what they do is like they'll suffer
a little bit to look good right
beauty is pain right so like i'm
thinking do i got to take that
philosophy too because i'm trying to be
comfortable as possible but still look
cool
but still look like different is it
painful
to scrub when you shower well hygiene's
different i'm thinking about like
um fashion okay well you asked his
hygiene routine though
yeah okay but what he really meant was
fashion
i guess it's two of the same they're
different i know i think the term he
uses grooming
but they complement each other yeah like
you gotta be high fashion you have to be
wealthy yeah yeah they're like different
categories that make up the same overall
understanding of a person
yeah it's like if i have a dope ass
shirt on but i've got seaweed stuck in
my teeth
that's not fashion that's not fashion
yeah it's grooming though
yeah or at one point it was kind of
fashionable like with the charcoal
black teeth remember the geishas yeah so
i might have
botched up that explanation okay so my
point is here
is i have this philosophy of comfort
first
so because i do everything around that
even my grooming takes that approach
totally dude you look
really comfortable thank you really
comfortable but sometimes
i'm not the cleanest person on earth you
might also have a power of making other
people
uncomfortable as well if you were to
like walk into their place of business
i've been told that i make people feel
very calm around me and happy
maybe emotional i i make up an emotional
where i don't in hygiene
how about that i feel like you guys
don't get to see like the full picture
like i do
but like you should really show off your
outfit for today well
i'm only filming from the waist i know
but like you should
show the bottom of your feet yeah it
hasn't gotten dark yet
it's early it's our first episode today
first the only place you wouldn't get
thrown out of is a gun store
oh really that's about it no i could eat
at a
i could eat at zippy's in hawaii true
okay no no
no no you got a buckle on your shorts
right now no it's like his waist pocket
thingy
no because i always fashion bro don't
let anybody
not i was wearing fanny packs before it
was cool
yeah that was true okay um see comfort
first right
i'm always losing my wallet because i
wear comfortable shorts
and then so i had to figure out a way to
get
my wallet it sounds like the beginning
of a commercial you're like i feel like
you have a perfect balance going on for
you joe cause like
hat is casual vest is casual uh your
shorts are casual right
but then you have your statement pieces
right you got your little bag that's
around your waist you got your watch
you've got your glasses yeah it's a
rolex you like completely balance
yourself out like 50 feet
like a hair tie because like you're
telling me that later on you're going to
take the hat off of some smooth moves
you know
because it gets in the way when i eat
[ __ ] that's so sick
but okay what is your what is your group
what is your group
what is your grooming routine [ __ ]
grooming routine
sorry you had me at the the hair tie
part i'm not going to say that
um point is he washes his hair
it's washed you're hygiene that's washed
it is washed it's washed
oh dang that's like
it's wet kinda no it's okay i was like
it's a little nappy
like cat williams grease let me tell you
what i've been doing okay
i start using conditioner now before i
just put it on your scalp
never put conditioner on your scalp i
did not know that either
at the tips of your hair we only have
hair on our skin only have skin no you
could if you have no
you have longer hair but for you steve
you could just get
a little bit of conditioner and just
kind of like have a little bit of hair
huh just go no
on the tips because your your hair is
short you asked what if it's three in
one
what if we use a three in one uh body
wash shampoo and conditioner thing that
saves time
oh then then put that on we're [ __ ]
it's on our skin
guys it's body wash hair conditioner
face wash
i think all guys are like that they just
let me just do one soap bro
yes it's just oil yeah so i started
using that i have separate face wash now
wow yeah so don't put on yourself
because you're going to get your scalp
all dry and flaky and gross you don't
want that
girl you should know this i've done this
all my life
no is it weird i only condition like
once a week
no okay i do it every day yeah that's
fine
i do it like once a week so i let like
my natural oil i even actually only
shampoo my hair and wash my hair maybe
like four times a week oh
i do it twice a day you're dirtier than
me
no i don't know what it also depends on
the type of person you're like how much
oil you produce how sweaty you get
so maybe you should be watching so
shower every day but like
my my hair washing i'll like sometimes
allow just like the natural
oils to kind of like do its thing until
it gets like oily then i'm like no no no
i can't get that
so i think like four times a week as
well wash my hair like every
four or five days oh you're nasty i
don't get greasy oh yeah
i don't get i don't sweat chicks are
different dude guys should have to
shower every [ __ ] single day yes
please every guy girls don't even fart
everyone
barely i don't know about that man
there's smelly girls out there
well no of course well maybe they just
he said no no of course
of course but but think about like the
amount of sweat that we can get even
from just
having taken a shower oh you're right
because guys will just sweat by
sitting down and then girls like
somehow doesn't happen yeah guys are
just born
more gross yeah they are definitely you
guys are just
the truth that's true but you know i've
been wearing the same uh deodorant since
high school
what's your brand old spice me too i i
tried to go to those like
non you know or those like safer
environments or like you know natural
not
i was like it just doesn't work the same
no why do you wear deodorant
there's a period of time that you have
to transition it takes like a solid week
when you transition to the natural stuff
i feel like it's gonna take me like a
month i tried it for like two weeks you
know i tried to wear like the stick
started going down and i was like
i was like this just isn't really doing
it for me you know like
how do you know the difference how do
you know that you could smell
yeah and you can feel it the sweatiness
i barely smelly
natural stuff doesn't plug up your your
sweat glands
why would you want that don't you want
to make girls horny yeah
why would you want to plug up your your
your attraction juices
i think that there's like maybe a
different understanding that we have of
attraction juices
it's called a pheromone there it is okay
yeah i think my armpit sweat is usually
not the thing that attracts women
um oh you'd be surprised i [ __ ] love
smelling
sweaty pits when it's mixed with
deodorant yeah that's what i'm saying
see it's gotta it's gotta have already
uh
a pleasing fragrant fragrant style i
like degree
that's a nice brand degree but i haven't
worn deodorant in two years
um yeah do you feel like you need it a
concerned face from julia right away
julia's like i have to say all day
chemicals on my body
smell it but she would she will see that
that's so bad but also early
if i didn't shower i wouldn't have done
that to you we'll do an armpit check
later in the day
he does sometimes here but this time it
was this one was a regular shower yeah i
take real showers now
with hot water what does that mean um so
like
okay let me tell you two ways i used to
take showers right
one is i would get the shampoo put it on
my head
and then use the rest of the soap to go
down to my face to my neck to my bottom
and baby but i focus on my nuts and my
ass a lot because that's where it gets
really bad
and then like here right yeah so then
the the most
rank areas i would do that and if i
already took a shower that day
then later on i'll just turn the water
on cold i just walk in do a 360 get out
no way
[Laughter]
joseph at least he did a 360.
yeah you should up that till 7 20 if you
really want to like double the dosage
there
i gotta be a sprinkler you're only
spinning
and then he's like waving his arm yeah
that's just not like a car wash you know
what i mean
it's just like yeah don't want to get
wet all right what about your hands
right when you go
to the bathroom you just kind of like
you rinse it for
like at least how long 20 seconds or one
minute or whatever right
yeah but then if you scrub with soap and
it kind of feels like overkill if you
keep doing it over and over and over
have to kill the germs why because you
have to kill the germs
julia are you an intense groomer uh no
no i don't think so i think um
especially in quarantine i've been like
really gross so i've actually cleaned up
for you guys so this is great
nice yeah thank you yeah you're welcome
i see my little sister man you zoom in
to work right
i do zoom in to work and i've been
wearing the same shirt for like a week
straight and no one has said it yeah i'm
like this is great
but is it like a basic where people
can't really tell or is it like you
could tell
no you could tell you could tell us the
same he said oh [ __ ] people
just don't say anything anyway because
it's like what kind of an [ __ ] wants
to
mention like hey haven't you been
wearing the same shirt for a whole week
when you make a knobs or base and you're
like how many of those shirts do you got
yeah that's a really tactful way of
asking that's a better way
wow you have a lot here are all the
thumbnails that i screenshotted i know
right
every day and i'm not stalking you i
swear
and there was a time where like i didn't
shout for like well no no i didn't wash
my hair for like two weeks
and then when i did wash my hair people
were like whoa did you recolor your hair
i'm like
nope just washed it and then they're
like oh okay i'm like
yep damn two weeks and it didn't like
dreadlock or anything like that
i mean i combed it but i touch water
every day
i can't go to sleep without water like
drinking it though the inside no i mean
like washing my body
the outside he goes in he does his 360.
he goes to bed he lies down
i think there's got to be a nighttime
scrub and a daytime scrub
but in between if you got a pool you're
all good
damn oh i'm you know i'm [ __ ] nuts
you can't even go camping with us i have
to be clean because if there's no shower
he's like there's if there's no one day
or i can shower i'm not down david cause
david's like that too right i have to be
able to wash my [ __ ] hair that's my
biggest thing
but what if there was a a nice lake and
you can jump into that
i could probably do it for a day or
whatever but i need i need some clean
water
why are your hair the most versus like
genitals armpits well
everything hopefully right if there's
access to water i want to wash
everything but my hair if it hits the
sun and i haven't shampooed it
it gets itchy as [ __ ] because i i i'm
just an oily human being if i let it
go past a day and take you as a greasy
man i mean thank you
because i work hard in it do you feel
like because you work like really really
hard at it
you'll never be able to like go back the
other way yeah for sure because i'm so
uncomfortable when i
haven't showered and if it's the next
day i'm like miserable uncomfortable
have you taken a smoke shower when
you're camping
i haven't done that actually when you um
when you go to the campfire you just
kind of like let the smoke hit you
and then you feel and smell the smoke on
your body so you don't feel dirty
that's why it would make me feel dirtier
yeah i it smells good you just don't
feel as dirty though yeah you don't feel
like like when you when you smell your
own sweat and all that [ __ ]
for me stickiness like whenever like if
i'm camping
and it's a really hot day and i'm
sweating all day like i feel disgusting
if i don't shower because i feel like
my skin is sticky yeah stickiness is
weird when you smell like barbecue wood
i don't know i don't like that smell at
all me and you can get a fire pit
and because our area doesn't have great
air circulation
when we had anyone over while we were
using the fire pit we gave everyone a
[ __ ]
campfire shower so everyone smelled like
smoke like from head to toe
yeah i experienced that that's true and
then our hoa is like you guys can't do
this [ __ ]
like you're giving everyone in the
neighborhood [ __ ] uh campfire showers
yeah dang what about you babe uh
i find showers to get in the way of what
i
actually want to do yes i don't like
showering
but i like i like the results gets in
the way of what you want to do
sometimes when you're like i don't know
watching a tv show you're like
i'd rather do this than go shower and
then you fall asleep and you're like
yeah i'm just i'm [ __ ] comfortable
okay for you you three guys when you
take uh
why am i excluded because of this reason
you just excluded yourself
oh okay got it hold on a second because
i already know what's gonna come out of
your mouth
so for you three when you guys get uh
get
a haircut that's the word when you guys
get a haircut is it a must for you to
bathe and shower like get all that hair
off of your body before you go to sleep
oh yeah absolutely yeah depends on how
lazy i
am i get the prickly neck i can't do it
anymore prickly neck drives me nuts
and then prickly sheets oh yeah yeah
totally uh
pillowcase absolutely weekly wife you're
definitely staring at me wife is not
good
that's true get me all prickly damn you
don't [ __ ]
you don't shower immediately i could
sleep on the street and be completely
fine
that's true people people are like your
girls joe and it's like well you don't
know
casey well he doesn't look gross no he
doesn't
i do you you pull it out i look like a
dirty homeless man and then you smell me
and it's like oh it's not that bad
yeah yes it's just regular homelessness
i'm all looks but we need to get close
enough and then he smells like a
homeless man no no
the reason why he looks this way though
who gets the credit
thank you my wife beautiful life clean
them up i did you
remember you got a homeless man off the
street do you not recall
i thought he lost weight and everything
before he needed a long-haired hip yeah
when tiff found me i was had jesus hair
uh wait were you fat back then i thought
you lost
i lost it all but i was i still had my
hair though he was anti-war
he slept on a futon with sheets that
look like
were at one point they were white but at
this point when i
met him they were this color and i
remember we cleaned the sheets for the
first time you looked at the mattress
i don't know how i dated you yeah yeah
what was it i brought you to him
i think that's the stupidest instant
[ __ ] connection
it was the deodorant and the vo that's
what it is
that's how you lock yourself in those
lips that's okay guys you did a great
job
this is a lesson to you guys out there
be disgusting because it gives a girl
uh a way to they can work on something i
get rolled up my sleeves i'm like okay
it's like pimple popping right like they
want to clean you up
just kidding i just made that up well
some girls i mean like maybe that's what
you tapped into you like puzzles no but
you do you
really do like pumpkins puzzles you like
organizing stuff and you saw me you're
like this guy's a mess i'm gonna
organize them
you're very good at that though cause
like you helped me out too
because i just would never get around to
doing anything
if yeah your room was such a fun project
because like it was
a hey come over to my place yeah come
over to my car
that's fun doing that i look at a mess
and i'm like can somebody do something
please i've got a lot of
personal tragedies that need a hero like
my bathroom
i have to say i just clean i don't do
cleaning
i do organizing yeah
while you're at it honey uh yeah can you
uh scrub that down
that's not me that's not what i'm doing
yeah like when i look at my room now
because it's like a big mess i'm like
what would tiff do
and then i stop and i'm like i'm kind of
lazy
lay down on my bed and i'm like yeah
this is better in all the years we've
known each other like almost a solid
decade
i've asked you to invite me so many
times
i know but she can't even get to
inviting you because she's so
disorganized
it's embarrassing i'm lazy it's like hey
tiff would you
is it because you have to clean up first
huh she just cleaned up first and then
she comes
off can you fix this excuse me thank you
point don't clean up if anything make it
messier yeah but it's
rude wait wait i i have we get house
cleaners and
i i feel the obligation to at least tidy
up a little bit before the house
cleaners get there
and we do i add extra mess i take a [ __ ]
and i leave it unflushed
and then i'm just kidding good cause
you're providing them jobs that's gross
i know no that's different though
because they're there to like do the
cleaning scrubbing
this is for organizing again to
completely
wait so you still okay so we have to
organize
so then they could get into the
neighborhood like tooth fairy that [ __ ]
and just like leave dollar bills and
random spa
you know what worked for me i've been
making my bed every single day
um my place looks [ __ ] dope what
worked for me
is starting with the raw space that
you're proud of
because no other spaces that i've had
were mine where i designed it i cared
about it
i wanted to look a certain way all that
stuff right because i didn't have the
money for it or i just didn't have the
creativity
so when my buddy helped me out with the
design of things he was like look
like when you do stuff with your bare
hands and you don't hire someone to
do it for you this is your creativity
and something that you're going to
cherish so when you wake up in the
morning you're going to want to make it
look
good right so now i get up and i'm like
oh [ __ ] the bed has to
look sick like and then you look and
you're like yeah this is [ __ ] sick i
want to come home to this [ __ ]
maybe that's what we should do because i
do it all in the house
and just destroy it so it's like you got
to do the art decoration
and then the production behind it and
then now you have a picture
of how you like it and then you're like
oh i don't want to [ __ ] up this picture
your house is [ __ ] immaculate though
dude by the way that's that's what you
do to your your body in the morning
you look at you you're like this [ __ ] is
perfect i need to dress it the right way
here we go but then sometimes my
standards are low and i'm like this is
better like this is good like i brushed
my teeth once and i'm like
[ __ ] pristine because my eyes don't
see the flaws
[Music]
you